Film Courage: What’s your process for developing
an idea?
Matthew Berkowitz, Filmmaker: That’s difficult.
Film Courage: What are you doing before you
write the screenplay?
Matthew: Well I’ll come up with an idea
right?
Or I’ll come up with a character or I’ll
come up with a theory and most of the time
for me it’s like a thesis, it’s something
and I think that might be because I love to
read so much literature and I kind of come
from philosophy and I develop a thesis or
something that I want to say and then I find
characters that I think can embody that purpose
and that can function in a story that kind
of carries this idea throughout it so I can
communicate what I want to say in a story
and through characters.
So it always starts with an idea or a thesis
or a theory that I to talk about and the characters
in the story kind of fall in line from there.
Then I’ll just kind of binge watch a bunch
of movies that apply and I’ll just write…you
know I carry a little notebook around me everywhere
I go because I don’t really type.
I mean I type but I don’t really write my
script until I’ve handwritten it a bunch
of times and a bunch of different ways and
I’ve kind of flushed out my characters and
only then do I write the plot because I think
that at least right now in the stories that
I’m trying to tell it’s the characters
motivate the plot rather than the plot motivating
the characters.
So I want to really know the characters like
they are friends of mine.
Like they are my best friends, my childhood
friends.
So once I know them, I kind of know the world.
Once I know the world, I know the story…so
that’s my process.
Film Courage: Interesting.
Do you ever get lonely when you finish writing
something because they were like your best
friend?
Because in a sense if it stops you’re almost
losing them for a little bit?
Matthew: I’ve never really thought about
it like that?
After you finish a film or finish a script
you’re kind of like “What now?”
You know?
“What do I do know?”
Because you’ve spent this three month period
of time every day thinking about these characters,
thinking about writing and thinking about
what’s next, thinking about how they say
this, think about how they’d say that.
So when it’s done you’re kind of like
“Oh man, I don’t want it to be over yet.”
And I think it’s the same thing when you
finish a film and you’re like “Oh my gosh,
I’m done shooting…that’s it?”
It happened so quickly.
That’s why you’ve got to get into editing
so you can keep it alive somehow and then
by the time you’re done you’ve got this
file that’s like a 120 gigabytes and it
took you a year and a half to make it and
you’re like “A year and a half turns into
a 120 gigabyte file or a DVD?”
So it’s kind of a weird sensation that you
have when you’re like all this boiled down
to this little thing that you can double-click
in a place and you just put it in the DVD
player and it plays.
But I think that’s what the whole process
is, it justifies the characters that you want
to write because they do get to play.
They do get to be on a big screen, they do
get to go someplace and other people can watch
and live and experience it for two hours.
So although when you are done with the script
it’s kind of over, it’s not really over
because the audience gets to live through
them, your audience gets to view it and it’s
like the second reincarnation of your film
is like having other people be touched by
what you’ve made.